[Music]
economists Wall Street traders and the
president regularly talk about this
america's gross domestic product as you
can see it generally rises over time but
right now the President and some others
say it's not rising fast enough
they say the country will be better off
if we can make the GDP rise at a 3% rate
or even more a year rather than the 2
percent rate it had been going at for a
while will explain why they say the
current rate isn't fast enough but first
you have to understand what GDP is and
how government statisticians measure it
to put it simply GDP is a measure of how
much stuff a nation produces with all of
the work that it does all of the apples
we pick from orchards the cars we
produce in factories the dinners we
serve at restaurants the flights we take
from airports the broken legs our
doctors fix in hospitals and more GDP is
what all of that work adds up to as a
nation we produce an enormous amount of
stuff every single year according to the
Commerce Department Americans produce
nearly 21 trillion dollars worth of
goods and services last year far more
than any other nation including China 21
trillion dollars let's put that big
number in perspective if all we did as a
nation was make cars that would be about
enough car production to build two giant
stacks of car towers to the moon in a
single year so how does the government
measure all that stuff to come up with
GDP the government's method is kind of
odd if it's a measure of how much stuff
we produce as a nation you might think
that government statisticians went
around counting all that production up
but that's not the way the government
does it instead what the government
measures is everything that we consume
the thinking goes like this
what is consumed has to be produced by
somebody somewhere if you measure
consumption you can figure out
production so here's how statisticians
calculate consumption first they can up
everything that's spent by consumers
that's the stuff you buy from day to day
then they add it to everything that's
spent by businesses on investment
that's the stuff businesses buy to grow
and make what you're producing and then
they add that to everything that's spent
by the government on space travel
housing the military and everything else
all together that equals their broad
measure of everything we consume as a
nation the formula is C plus I plus G
then the statisticians make some
adjustments sometimes we make goods or
provide services that get sent overseas
for example America exports a lot of
soybeans that counts toward production
too so we add that to the mix sometimes
we also consume products that we've
imported think about your iphones and
televisions imported from china that's
the stuff we consume that wasn't made
here in america subtract that from the
mix now there's two other adjustments to
make sometimes we consume stuff that was
made earlier and placed in a warehouse
or stuck on the shelf of a store think
about a blouse that was placed in
inventory months ago that somebody buys
today that's something we might consume
today that was produced before to adjust
for these timing changes the
statisticians correct for changes in
inventories they also correct for
inflation prices of stuff tend to go up
over time and statisticians adjust for
those changes taken altogether you get
GDP so what's going on now President
Trump is worried that GDP isn't growing
fast enough between 1950 and 2000 GDP
grew by 3.7 percent per year that means
if we produced 1,000 cars in 1 year we
produced 1037 the next year and 1075 the
year after that since 2000 GDP has grown
by 2 percent a year that would mean 1020
cars in the second year and 1040 in the
year after that changes in the growth
rate can really add up over time at a
three point seven percent growth rate
GDP doubles in 20 years at a 2 percent
growth rate it takes 35 years to double
that's a long time to wait for more
growth
slower GDP growth means slower growth
and family incomes business profits
wealth and prosperity too that's why the
President and others worry when GDP
doesn't grow fast so how can we make it
grow faster remember GDP is a measure of
how much our workers produce two ways to
make GDP grow faster or to add more
workers to the labor force or to
increase the productivity of the ones
we've already got would that make us
better off as a nation well it would
probably help a lot but GDP isn't
everything
it doesn't tell you how the income and
economy produces is distributed between
rich and poor it doesn't tell you
whether your air and water are clean and
it also doesn't tell you whether people
are happy producing all that stuff
that's why we need to look at a lot more
than GDP to know if we're getting better
off as a nation